and this is a Fox News Alert the AP is
now projecting that JD Vance has won the
Ohio GOP Primary Senate race joining us
now with reaction former Speaker of the
House Newt Gingrich
he was in the single digits Mr Speaker
and then somebody by the name of Donald
J Trump endorsed him and here he is with
a significant win tonight along with uh
I think 11 other candidates that look
like endorsed by Trump that are going to
win as well what does that tell you
well first of all I want to watch the
national media which had set this up as
the big test you know did Donald Trump
really have any stroke left or was he no
longer capable of doing anything but I
also think it's an important comment
about JD Vance this is a different
Republican party uh JD Vance's
background having written a book about
his childhood having grown up uh
intimately aware of Appalachia of the
Ohio River Valley of blue-collar workers
of local small farmers uh this is a guy
who is going to bring on the one hand a
tremendous intellectual and artistic
capability on the other hand a real
down-home Grassroots populism and he is
going to I think be an enormous breath
of fresh air in the Congress and I think
combined with people like Herschel
Walker you're going to see a very
different Republican Senate next year
but it's certainly from Donald Trump's
standpoint an enormously Big Win not
just JD Vance but as you point out I
think 9 of the 11 people he's endorsed
have already won and the other two I
think are still being counted uh to do
that in Ohio they're going to win today
it looks like
Trump will have a perfect night in Ohio
tonight
I am sure that he's excited well and if
that happens look I think we have a lot
of great candidates I personally think
Ron DeSantis has a tremendous future as
an example or somebody like Rick Scott a
number of Governors around the country
but the truth is if Trump retains his
hold on the base of the Republican party
that he currently has and particularly
if he starts shifting towards describing
a better future I think that he will
consolidate and almost certainly end up
as the nominee tonight's a very big
night in terms of 2024 as well as in
terms of 2022 and it fits what we're
seeing the fact is inflation matters uh
collapse at the border matters crime
matters high prices for gasoline and
Food Matters and in the middle of all
this uh the corruption of the of the
Biden Family Matters uh and you know I
think the Democrats are going to
discover that the January 6th committee
he doesn't matter to most Americans and
they're going to discover that a
hard-line pro-abortion extremism doesn't
appeal to most Americans and in fact
will accelerate their loss of
African-American and Latino voters who
are culturally conservative so you're in
the middle of a genuine Revolution Ohio
is one of the places reminding us that
in the real world outside of Washington
and the New York Times and the big
networks in the real world that
Revolution is still underway Mr Speaker
stay with us let's step in this is JD
Vance now who has just been declared the
winner in the Ohio Republican Senate
primary endorsed by Donald Trump winning
by a pretty significant margin based on
our numbers let's step in and hear him
and this team has been loyal to me
through good times and bad when things
were rough when things were good we
didn't have leaks in this campaign we
didn't have people stabbing each other
in the back we were a team and we will
be a team all the way to November
[Applause]
um I have absolutely got to think
the 45th
the president of the United States
Donald J Trump ladies and gentlemen
one forgiveness example of what could be
in this country ladies and gentlemen
remember 2019 when wages were going up
and not down remember 2019 when workers
were doing well in this country not
struggling terribly thanks to the
president for everything for endorsing
me and I got to say a lot of the fake
news media out there and and there are
some good ones in the back there there's
some bad ones too let's be honest
but they wanted to write a story that
this campaign would be the death of
Donald Trump's America First agenda
ladies and gentlemen it ain't the death
of the America First agenda
it wasn't just the president of course
we had a lot of endorsements especially
some of our early endorsements I want to
make sure I give some shout outs to
Penny Nance a great advocate for life
and for people all across the country
you know uh let me go back to Speaker of
the House Newt Gingrich former speaker
you know he said something there that I
think is extremely relevant
um I I do believe the damage that has
been caused in just a short period of
time uh everything from inflation to
high gas prices to open borders uh Law
and Order uh Safety and Security even
running out of covet test Afghanistan
it's been a disaster
um I do believe that my feeling is the
America First make America great again
now save America agenda is going to be
what propels the Republicans to Victory
both in 22 and 24 it's a hope it's a
prayer because the country needs to
change directions quickly
well look I think that's right and uh I
just talked as recently as yesterday
with Kevin McCarthy who is really
leading a remarkable effort in the house
to develop a very positive agenda very
much like the contract of America the
kind of thing you and I have talked
about I sense that in the Senate uh
Senator McConnell's much more favorable
now than he was earlier to having some
kind of a contract and that's Motion in
the right direction I personally believe
when you look at the disaster that big
government socialism and woke liberalism
has created I think it's very likely
that you're going to be somewhere
between 25 and 70 seat gain in the house
and at least I think at least a four
seed gain in the Senate so there's an
opportunity in January for Republicans
with people like JD Vance and people
like Herschel Walker new people new
ideas new approaches uh there's a real
opportunity that we could set a new
pattern for America forced Biden every
day to choose between the American
people and his radical left and end up
going into 24 as a party with Big Ideas
big Solutions offering a better American
future if that happens this will be the
end of the Roosevelt era after almost
100 years and you will see a really
dramatically different America by 2026.
I'm very optimistic that this can happen
it's very interesting because there's
not a single success story that the I
call them the the climate alarmist
religious cult or new Greendale
socialist is not a single success story
so they get this this leaked opinion
that's not even complete yet and they
rush to judgment oh we'll run on
abortion
even if you consider yourself
pro-choice you don't support abortion up
until the the moment of birth we have
about a minute left sir
well that's right I mean if you look at
the extremism of the radicals who would
literally allow abortion on the day of
the birth would allow the baby to be
killed after it's born uh basically
infanticide I think it's crazy and
remember this is a Democratic party
which was on the verge of replacing
Mother's Day with birthing persons day
my newsletter at getting rich 360 uh
this weekend is going to be on which
which do you identify with if you think
it ought to be birthing persons day you
ought to be a Democrat if you think it
ought to be Mother's Day you ought to be
a republican it's that simple and that's
why they're going to lose and I think
lose maybe for two generations because
they're just nuts
yeah well I mean look if if Kevin
McCarthy if you're right and apparently
the president was not angry at the tapes
that were released and they have made
amends that's between them I'm not
getting in the middle of that but if
they follow your lead that you laid out
an agenda a positive agenda to save the
country like he did in 94 it will be 94
2010 and and maybe even bigger anyway Mr
Speaker thanks for being with us hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else